I [ __ ] up that Sandler interview it
was so bad what happened
had you met him no I've never met him I
never met him and and I'm obviously Adam
sand Adam Sandler David Spade Norm
Macdonald Chris Rock Chris Farley that
generation
is their thumb prints Forever on me like
Chris Rock stand up bring the pain yeah
he's my favorite it's the it's
it is the thing I watched where I said I
want to do that like that I don't I'll
never do that but that's what I strive
for that that strutty had on stage
Stop I mean everything was like a bull
whip sky like y'all and it was so
jarring of so amazing and then Sandler
the way happy he developed all these
great movies that just spokes the price
is wrong [ __ ] yeah you're looking bad
like all these like just a way to take
like your inside jokes with your friends
and make them inside jokes with the
world and then you know Spade was such
Spade Norm Dennis Miller a little older
but like Kevin Nealon all these guys
they're just so so influential on my
sensibility so Whitney hit me up and
said hey you know it's a pandemic
she's like yo we're doing it I'm doing
an interview with Adam Sandler
uh you want to come by my house and and
if you want she's like I would love some
help interviewing Sandler you know such
a [ __ ] star so if you could just come
and we'll figure something out for her
podcast no no no for uh
we're raising money for Comics that need
the money for the pandemic so I go over
to Whitney's backyard I kind of [ __ ]
around in the backyard I'm I'm messing
around I'm on I'm on YouTube yeah I'm
doing whatever the you know just to make
it fun make it Interactive
and then she goes to interview Sandler
she says come on in we're gonna
interview Sandler and and I I got my
heart was racing and I got and then he
just pops up on the screen he's like hey
and Whitney's like uh Adam I'm here with
Bert Chrysler and he's like okay
and I
went
full [ __ ] [ __ ] dolphin full full
baby walrus like just like
and I
talked for about 10 minutes he I don't
think he said a word and I just said
everything wrong you talked for 10
minutes I said do you have Netflix and
Whitney's like huh and Adam's like I'm
sure in his head he was like well I just
I I ran wrong it was do you have Netflix
um uh I can't wait to see your new movie
precious gems that's not the name of it
um I just showed my daughters and I sat
and watched Happy Madison that's the
name of his production company not the
movie we watched um hey you want to hear
a cool story about when I was in college
and he's like huh and I was like when I
was 22 years old I got voted by the
number one party animal in the country
holding that whole story I did all of it
I did all of it sorry man I'm sorry I
vomited I vomit and Theo I thought it
went well I was like nailed it that's
alcoholism left Whitney's going oh Jane
you need the closer bring in the closer
you Adam Sandler's probably going who
the [ __ ] is this Bert Chrysler guy sign
him to a deal covert get Chrysler on the
line This Guy's hot we need him first
person to call me was uh first person to
call me was uh Big Jay oakerson and he
goes he goes hey man just letting you
know we're going to trash you and I went
huh he's like we're on the zoom next and
and we are crying laughing and I go oh
what and he goes that Sandler interview
I go good huh he goes good
he goes you asked him if he had Netflix
I go do you think he doesn't and he goes
Bert he has a 300 million dollar deal at
Netflix he definitely has Netflix I went
huh he's like you call this movie
precious gems I go that's something Amy
goes no it's uncut he's like you named
the movie Happy Madison it's Happy
Gilmore Billy Madison Bert we are going
you didn't let him talk it's the biggest
movie star in the world and you didn't
let him talk and I went I just started
going like it was that bad and he goes
I'm we're going online right now we're
gonna trash you and hung up and I went
huh and then my buddy my buddy Mike um
apps no no no uh does podcasts with Greg
Luke Valentine nope anyway uh Mike Mike
God damn it he's he does the podcast
with Martin does a podcast with Greg
Fitzsimmons they do Sunday papers uh oh
Mike uh vecchione no anyway he calls me
and he goes that [ __ ] Sandler
interviews epic like I told him I go
have you seen my new special my special
just dropped it's called uh it's called
Hey Big Boy or that dude I was out of
control I was out of my house Stone
sober Stone sober out of control so this
is why space a cool dude right
unprovoked I gotta [ __ ] you know
Spade sometimes voice texting oh yeah
and he's like uh Chrysler
[ __ ] Sandler interviews epic and I'm
like I'm in bed going the next day going
I'm gonna I'm gonna have a drink today
this is the [ __ ] worst day of my life
yeah this is the day next day and he
goes hey man I talked to stanler he just
watched your special he [ __ ] loved it
dude he loves you you're the best we all
love you don't sweat it and I was like
I like by the way didn't need to do that
right didn't need to do that didn't need
to leave that message didn't he let me
know hey don't worry about it you didn't
[ __ ] up that bad then I signed a deal
with the Happy Madison to do a movie wow
yeah so like everything worked out great
like want to have Happy Madison uh
pitched a movie I think yeah yeah and
then uh signed up to do a movie so
everything's like everything worked out
fine but like man I that interviews you
can find it online
yeah I can't wait to watch that when I
get cringy I might even watch it in the
car dude
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one